[موسيقى] [موسيقى]
أجنبية
نعمل على إخراج الحبوب من
أوكرانيا
بوتين يستغل الجوع ،
فهو يستخدم الأمن الغذائي كأداة حرب قاسية ،
فقد أغلق الموانئ الأوكرانية
وأوقف تصدير 20 مليون طن من الحبوب في
جميع أنحاء العالم.
العالم يطلب فدية أنا هنا في تركيا
لمناقشة خطة إخراج الحبوب
بدعم من الأمم المتحدة ،
نحن واضحون أن السفن التجارية بحاجة
إلى ممر آمن
[الموسيقى]
دور تركيا المهم للغاية في
المساعدة في إخراج الحبوب  من
أوكرانيا وأريد حقًا أن أشيد بمافليت
والحكومة التركية للدور القيادي
الذي لعبوه في المساعدة في حل
هذا الوضع الصعب للغاية والذي إذا
لم يتم حله من المحتمل أن يؤدي إلى جوع هائل في
جميع أنحاء العالم ،
فمن الواضح أنه سيساعد
إذا  سوف يرفع الروس ما يعتبر
أساسًا حصارًا في البحر
الأسود وحصارًا على أوديسا والذي من الواضح أنهم لن
يظهروا أي رغبة في رفعه
ولكن هذا مفتاح حقيقي هنا أه وهكذا
أنت أعلم أنك تعلم أننا ندرك أن
تركيا تتحدث إلى روسيا حول هذا الأمر ، فنحن
بالتأكيد نرحب بمشاركة تركيا
في محاولة
التوسط في نوع من
الترتيبات حيث يمكن نقل هذه الحبوب
عن طريق البحر ولكن أعتقد
أنه لا يزال يتعين القيام بذلك.  لمعرفة ما إذا كان
ذلك سيكون قابلاً للتطبيق